leave it to be new take my beanie off a
little bit Michael the east side of LA
mm-hmm 43rd and San Pedro yes
well stepdad and my mom he raised me got
me my first job first car you know
things like that well mom did drugs and
alcohol on the weekends and pop smoke
gum yeah but they did the best yeah they
did the best I learned a lot I felt
alone a lot
I didn't feel loved you know because all
I got was a speeding can I say that
beatings and withdrawn yeah
very tough kid no my baby brother he was
like the chosen child never got in
trouble you might have got one or two
weapons the best of clothes he ate real
good he got the most attention my two
sisters they were girls so they got you
know hand-me-down dresses and you know
they didn't get the beatings either
seemed like that was the only one like
the black sheep in the family yeah like
15 14 and a half 15 ya know I got my GED
in prison though yes from friend's house
to girl's houses slept in abandoned
buildings parks stuff like that you know
places like that I went to ye at 16 I
started doing real prison time from 18
on a I'm 50 now
my first case was direct sales and my
second case was a robbery my third case
was assault with a deadly weapon fourth
case with a GBI
that's like assault with a deadly weapon
with great bodily injury and then drug
cases in drug cases yes yes I have three
they're all grown Prison yes on drugs
yes of course well got at a prison they
put me in a drug rehab they had bedbugs
in the place so I just left and I've
been downtown every sentence that was
just last time I saw you
over the last time I saw you yeah since
then
cooking you crack it's not cocaine no
mortgage cry yeah
music career since I was 18 in prison I
didn't do anything
you know anything yeah had to we liked
it or not you had to stay strong stay
strong I came to I didn't with job i
came i was Jordan in County Jail I came
to the point of it being like home you
know when I would get out it's like a
vacation you know so I would go back
home come on over vacation go back home
come on a vacation yeah
it became home more so than the streets
about four months for five months for
five months ten that's the new thing
tense now they're very cardboard box I
remember that
yes cover up with the cardboard box and
go to sleep yes yes that's the big thing
now that's the big thing but I'm staying
with the female and it's her tent and
I'm waiting to get my money so I can buy
me a tent and you know and do all the
rest of the stuff that comes along with
it yes
dear friends let's be honest
and really this is it
yeah I know it's sad to say but honey
gave up you know do you think the prison
time and the lack of education and
without my GED in prison okay that's
good but do you think there's so many
kind of counts against you that just is
hard for you to just get go back
together and get back on track well
actually it's the drugs
mister drugs mister dress I've tried
everything from prison to programs to
church hospital mental hospitals I've
tried everything they give me is called
PLC Prolia outpatient clinic they give
me an injection now it's supposed to
curb my cravings doesn't work so I'm
just
you don't you don't see any any chance
of breaking free of them no no no i-i've
came to the point to accept it
just accept it there's no way to be
functional and have a job and chauffeur
work and do you no good I could you're
not good yes I could but I receive SSI
don't you guess so
keep it going keep it going keep it
going
yes I know that's sad to say but there's
my life mm-hmm my family knows where I'm
at if they want to come see me or pick
me up they can come yes oh yes matter of
fact it happened two weeks ago my sister
came to name pick me up took me to her
house cleaning me up and you know to
shave and fed me for a couple of weeks
and all that stuff but I came back down
here
[Music]
yes my kids yes yes I still have a
little bit a little bit but they watch
me when I come over their house and it
makes me feel uncomfortable I've never
stolen anything from them but it makes
me feel uncomfortable
everybody's you know eyes on me you know
they looking at me look at my hands you
know my face and well when I was a kid
about eight years old my babysitter she
was a female she raped me I thought it
was how it was supposed to be feel good
and I got older went to prison
my celly got me drunk overpowered me
anyway me baby I didn't talk about that
we haven't talked about that that's not
something you talk about but it didn't
kill me it made me stronger you know
it's hard for me to trust people
you know and to be honest I kind of grew
to like it you know it's just the way it
is it affects me to this day women yes
my relationships with women
man is just now yeah yeah lemon yes and
you've attended how is it affecting you
so you're more aggressive you're rougher
yeah aggressive aggressive yeah they
tend to like it like that yes you do yes
it is
decisions or certain things that
happened to you yes yes you were younger
than just yes yes I had the opportunity
you go stay with my auntie and all her
kids are normal and why did they say
what's normal but they're pretty normal
have jobs wives homes you know good jobs
and on it and it kind of stuff I think
that would been better for me but I did
not go I didn't want to go when I was
too stuck up under my mom then I was
living a carefree life come in when I
want excuse me
come in when I want to do drugs drink
you know have the women over and you
know stuff like that no responsibilities
it's nothing is it yeah but I need
responsibilities
I need that yet that grounds you it
gives you reason to push flow and
grounds you grounds you yes yes it does
well engine temptations and not have any
responsibilities
it takes you apart yes it does yes it
does
yeah and then you get used to it
having no respond down here no response
yes yeah it is it is it is but that's
normal to have those things in life you
know that's a normal mmm what is normal
you know but that's what people expect
us to do would have you know those are
things we supposed to get out of life so
we can know comfortably when we get old
I'm look at my face I'm almost there man
I'm 50
[Music]
to work yes of course it makes you happy
yes you're doing something you feel you
love to do that just gives your life
like it grounds you music meaning make
sure what makes you happy
yes yes it does yes it does it's a gives
you peace all the above yes welcome
thank you thank you